it's better always to enjoy applause
before then after mr. goon thank you for
joining us today I would like to open by
asking you how you approach leadership
strategy and execution differently at
Nissan versus at Renault given that each
company has very different cultural
contexts well you know the French the
French way of managing and the
leadership in French expresses itself in
a completely different terms than Japan
I mean I I knew it I knew it from the
beginning so in a certain way you have
some fundamental fundamentals which are
the same and we're going to probably
talk about what are these fundamentals
but the way you exercise these
fundamentals are completely completely
different in Japan I don't run meeting
the same way that and I run them in
France
I don't reward people the same way than
I do it in France what is expected even
in terms of communication you don't do
the same things in Japan they are not
the tools are not the same the words are
not the same the way even you shape your
strategy is not the same so what we have
to do when you are in a situation where
you are managing through a different
culture is you want to make sure about
what is the content which usually is
very common and then what is the
packaging of the content which has to
take in consideration with how they can
consideration the culture and I can tell
you that mean we're talking about France
and Japan but it's varied between the
United States or China or India every
time you have to make sure about make
the difference about what's the content
what do I need to do what is the essence
of my message and second you know what
is the best way what is the most
efficient way to make to make this
message go through when you join Nissan
in 1999 the company had been suffering
from major losses over the
seven years and only three of its 48
models were profitable you turned the
company around and restored it to
profitability within two years as both
the company outsider and the first
foreign CEO of the company how did you
earn the support of your team and
motivate them to execute on your plan
yeah well you know 1999 the situation
was really bad in Nissan and when you
are you know taking a responsibility for
situation which is bad it's it's also a
strength because you don't need to
explain to people that situations but
they know it already they know and you
need to know also that the solution is
always here you don't have to look yeah
I mean you don't need to invent the
solution you know that people know
already that it's bad and second that
the solution exists but it's buried
inside the company so your job is it's
very simple in a certain way is just
make sure that you make the very lucid
diagnosis of the situation very lucid no
emotion no you no sugarcoating no
politics no complacency extremely lucid
assessment of the situation and listen
to what people have to say to a very
simple question why are we in this
situation what do you think can we
improve what are the things that should
be done then you have your own personal
doing about what are the priorities
because you end up with a laundry list
of measures that needs to be done and
obviously you cannot work on 120
objective or on 200 objective you need
reading to concentrate them into two or
three because that's the only thing you
can absorb at the level of a big
organization make sure the other right
one and start to work on them so you
know in Nissan in 1999 everybody knew
that me son had the problem the only
thing is that nobody recognized that the
problem was in his own area you know if
I was in sales I was blaming the product
planner that they were not able to come
with the car competitive with Toyota if
I was in the product planner I said well
I read product but the design is not
good the designer said what the
engineers are messing up with me so
everybody in a certain way felt good
about what they were doing but the
company what had the problem
so you need to change this by saying
okay we understand that the other guys
are not doing the job but what we want
from you is what you can do you know in
your own area even if you think it's not
very important what you can do in your
own area in order to solve to solve the
problem so lucid diagnosis no compare no
no no complacency finding the bits of
solution inside the company put them in
perspective put them into into
priorities put it in a way which is
attractive you know because what is
management about management and
particularly the ship is about is asking
people to do things that they don't want
to do that's it that's manager mmm-hmm
I mean you don't manage any situation
everything is okay you know that's not
management that's supervision that's
administration etc what's really
management and leadership you're going
to ask you're going to have okay say
people don't want to cut headcount they
don't want to restructure they don't
want to you know close down plants they
don't want to retreat from markets where
they have been for many years let them
want to stop some activities they I want
to sell assets doesn't want to do that
okay so the very simple question of
management is how do you bring them to
do this and keep their motivation and
being convinced that doing the right
thing that's that's management and
that's leadership and for this the basic
element is put it in perspective
give yourself a an objective that
everybody says oh that's what we want to
achieve so it helps them go through the
tough situation where they will do
things that they don't want to do but I
know it's for the photo writing and this
is the Nissan story that's exactly the
Nissan sorry when I arrived in Japan
1999 one of the reasons for which Nissan
was in trouble is there were a lot of
decision which needed to be taken five
years ago were not taken but a lot of
people used to tell you you know you are
in Japan you cannot close down the plant
you cannot reduce headcount you cannot
undo cross-shareholding you cannot touch
the carry too you cannot touch the
seniority system you cannot you cannot
you cannot do a lot of things that
nobody wanted to touch so there was
absolutely no way you're going to fix
the company without touching all these
so we start say okay look are we all
committed to say we're going to come
back to profit and gonna grow this
company again yes no doubt unanimity
okay let's commit to this we all commit
to this and say okay now we're going to
start to explain what is the road and as
you know the Nissan revival plan
challenge every single taboo because
we've done everything which was
forbidden and people said you would not
be able to do but with clear commitment
to return to profitability within the
first year within the first year of the
plan so that's the way you drive people
you know that's what management is about
put in front of them something that they
want really to do to achieve that is
really significant for them significant
for them not only theoretically but
pragmatically they they are connected
with this victory that they are proud of
having revived the company but it was
good for them for their salary for that
career for the compensation for their
stock options for their benefit for
their retirement for everything then
after you align this okay now say now we
have to do the job at the end of this
year you are planning to launch the
Nissan Leaf an electric vehicle that
uses lithium-ion battery technology and
will be one of the early zero emission
cars on the market hmm incidentally as
part of our first-year curriculum we
watch the movie who killed the electric
car and I understand that you're
collaborating with that movies producers
to create a sequel called revenge of the
electric car
no it is true it is true enough it again
we spent many hours with them and they
came to Tokyo and F in the car and
hopefully it's going to be an
interesting one okay what is your
strategy for driving adoption and
becoming a leader in the electric
vehicle market in the US and globally
well you know first if you want to
innovate if you want to innovate you
have to accept from the beginning that a
lot of people are going to think that
you're a fool you're playing with
shareholders money you're taking bets
that should not be taken that this would
never work etc etc and that's exactly
what we're hearing today that's exactly
what I'm reading today and it's
absolutely unbelievable unbelievable to
see how much short-sighted how much
short-sighted probably the media and a
lot of analysts are are about what we
are how we understand the situation in
which the car
so we decided after analyzing everything
to say okay zero emission is the way to
go it doesn't mean that all the cars are
going to be zero mission but there is a
huge and tremendous bull var for the
development of the zero emission cars
and we can spend a lot of time explain
why but anyway obviously today people
we've invested already six billion
dollars on this project and he'll say
well you know what if this is not going
to be a big success it's going to be a
tremendous a tremendous way on the
performance the financial performance of
the company first I think is going to be
a tremendous success and I think this is
the way of the future and we can spend a
lot of time explaining it but what I'm
going to tell you is that we are in the
final phase before the launch the launch
will come by the end of 2010 in fact
it's going to be mass marketed in the
United States starting November or
December 2010 at the same time in in in
Japan I understand that even we showed
the leaf on in Stanford campus professor
I think you've driven it you know I mean
the only I mean you have to go into this
car drive it to understand that's real
that's not a kind of enhanced golf cart
you know where you have this is this is
a real car and on top of this the basic
assumption is it's affordable makes a
lot of sense and we're offering the zero
mission as a premium we're not asking
consumer to pay for the zero mission
that doesn't work is you're going to get
the zero emission as as a premium so
again you have to have vision this
vision has to be based on understanding
about the dynamics of the market
globally and then you have to pursue
this vision no matter what you have to
build motivation inside your company
this is easy because you're saying okay
we want to be leader in technology that
is meaningful for the consumer and
although in some people all the Renault
people are buying into it then we need
to come to the consumer and tell him you
know tell the consumer that's a great
product which is affordable and on top
of this is going to allow you to drive
without the guilt of the melting of the
icebergs
the change of the seasons and the
temperature etc I think it's going to be
very powerful but again before it starts
there is always a doubt and now we are
in the period of time where a lot of
people are throwing at you a lot of
stones by saying that's not going to
work and then you have a lot of comments
from competitors saying you know you're
too much bullish is not going to well
obviously what you want competitors to
say is he's in the right direction and
say ok he's in the right direction and
what is your car well I have no electric
cars so what's what's the situation
I am absolutely absurd I mean we open we
open already in the United States we
open the possibility for people already
to be we want to be on the list for the
photo electric car we had more than
35,000 people already I'm not talking
about the feats obviously Fred Smith
from Federal Express and the postal
services and electric company all of
them want that want to order the car by
the 10,000 we're not talking about them
we're talking about you know the people
who say ok this is a good thing and we
want it to happen and particular if you
tell me is going to be at the same price
than the regular car I want to go for it
so I think it's going to be very
powerful Nissan and Renault have a
unique alliance in which Renault has a
44% ownership stake in Nissan Nissan has
a 15% ownership stake in Renault and you
act a CEO of both companies what are the
unique opportunities and challenges at
this relationship and how do you handle
conflicting interests between Nissan and
Renault well that's that's an
interesting that's an interesting point
you know we have been we have been in
this alliance for the last 10 years that
mean we are probably the two companies
with the more sustainable track record
in terms of alliances because
practically every single other alliance
that happened in our industry was blown
away everything I remember in 1999 we
made the renault-nissan Alliance
immediately after the DaimlerChrysler
Alliance Daimler and krauser came
together and then Renault Nissan came
together and then they mark riser and
up to me she and then when the
DaimlerChrysler alliance came together
and we came together there was a lot of
commands
Damon Eliezer was this is Alliance made
in heaven
two very rich and powerful company and
attractive brands coming together
they're going to do a lot of things on
change the world and when renault-nissan
came together say two mules doesn't make
a horse what Wall Street Journal Wall
Street Journal 1999 I have all the track
records all the media everything okay
nobody talked about this but yeah we
have to have the we have everything
there okay the tools started to work and
then the two beautiful people started to
work and at the end of the day after ten
years Democrats Mitsubishi
you know the story and we sit there
which means that it's better to be a
mule than a horse in the car industry
more resistant more resistant to the
shocks and to the to the problem this is
due to the fact the fact that we had a
very pragmatic approach no grandiose
scheme of you know we're too different
than we're going to be one and all the
decisions going to be taken from one
place and we're going to have a super
holding company don't it doesn't work it
doesn't work
we took the lines as a marriage between
two people okay
when two people marry I mean are also
probably some of you are not but those
who have some experience in marriage
nobody won't become the other you know
you know my wife was saying they were
going to become one but how about you
become like me I'm not sure I'm not sure
I'm going to be very motivated exactly
under reverse same thing you know I'm
gonna ask away
so being different is very important
remaining difference is very important
having common goals having common
strategy but at the same time have your
own autonomy cultivating things together
but even I mean this is very important
diversity within uniformity you know
commonality with autonomy that's the way
the world works that's why it works so
in a certain way we try to inspire
ourselves from the basic
Dushan of human being of humankind by
saying we need to make sure that you
know even for the sake of business sense
we do not violate common sense or human
concerns we need always to to maintain
the car and frankly the result has been
that even though they've been a lot of
pressure on me to try to say why don't
you make a merger between the two
companies and you don't you know get one
team etc it doesn't work I cannot make
one team of Japanese and French managing
a company which would be neither
Japanese nor French okay it doesn't work
you know identity is the basis of
motivation identity is the basis of
success its basis of performance you
need to connect to something you need to
make sure that you're working for your
own team for your own country for your
own etc you need to belong somewhere in
order to go and conquer the world if you
don't know why you're doing this you're
going to lose your motivation so we have
been following this very pragmatic
approach obviously they've been a lot of
conflicts have been a lot of difference
but every time came back to this common
sense about you know if there is no
win-win we don't do it we're not going
to force one decision from one company
to the other decisions for Japan for
Nissan been taken in Tokyo always
decision for Renault always taken in
Paris don't confuse the two company but
at the same time always push for more
synergies developing things in common
putting things in common always for the
sake of each company benefit if you
maintain this kind of culture extracted
not from any book because there is no
reference but extracted from common
sense you can go you can go very you can
go very very far and frankly I think
because Renault and and Nissan and Japan
and French and Japanese people and
French people are so different that it
was obvious for everybody when you start
to see that oh you know maybe the two
companies are very similar we're going
to merge them together now here here
here comes trouble because there are
multiple identities within each company
and if you don't respect them you're
going to be you're going to be in
trouble that's why that was absolute
no merger which worked in the car
industry all of them are being sold or
collapsed you know look at sub sub being
sold and Jaguar being sold and then
Chrysler look what happened with
Chrysler after the grand news story that
we have been told in 1990 I mean you
have every single example which happened
it was not respected and it was not
respected because it was violating
violating common sense we are the only
survivor in this and that's why people
say why when it's a question of time
yeah it's a question of time before we
start to see problem no we're not going
to see problem as long as we maintain
the same pragmatic prudent prudent
approach to the to the lines how do you
identify leadership potential in a
person and how do you attract and
develop the best and brightest people in
your organization oh that's interesting
there are some basic conditions I mean
if you don't see them forget about
leadership first one very simple very
simple I had my first test first one if
somebody doesn't listen no way very
simple you sit down with anybody you
don't start discussing discussion in
cetera if it's not listening to you even
when you and the test is you start a
boring conversation if you're very
interesting it's very easy for will you
listen no no you go for a very boring
conversation you know and if the person
really listens and really try it cetera
that that's a very good start a leader
first is a listener very that's
absolutely basic condition if you're not
a listener you're never gonna write any
you can be a leader but you're not going
to go very far the second basic also
condition is I've never seen such a
thing as a boring leader leader not
nothing neither is always somebody
interesting somebody who can connect
with you very important very important I
mean so if I'm sitting with somebody and
you know after 15 minutes I want to go
to the next meeting I know it's it's not
very good so ability to connect ability
to be interested and being interesting
is also a very important
feature and you know that this is
something that you don't learn in school
or university it is something that you
developed by yourself everybody has his
own skills etc so I would say being a
listener being able to connect with
people are two absolutely basic
condition for leadership for the rest
you know efficiency ability to
communicate openness curiosity
intelligence etc we've seen great leader
who are not smart you will probably know
know a lot of them that mean they're not
smart I mean here very common no but
it's true I mean then they're not smart
and we've seen a lot of people extremely
smart who never never were able to take
any leadership position so I don't think
this is something discriminating I have
never seen a leader who was boring or at
least at the beginning here may be
boring idea you know after after five or
never and somebody who don't listen or
observe or try to see okay what's the
situation which I am what role have
mentors played in your life and what
advice do you have for us for finding
mentors
oh it's careers very important mentors
very important particularly but what
they teach you what not to do
I had many bosses in my career because I
started you know like a simple engineer
and I learned as much with the from the
managers or the leaders who are making a
lot of things which shocked me as from
the people who were inspiring me both of
them are very important why because the
guy you know who is your boss and all of
a sudden you say well you know he
doesn't communicate well I'm not
motivated etc you're learning you're
learning you're learning the basics
because you're going to always think
every time one will be in leadership
position I don't want to become like X Y
or Z who where my leader I want to make
sure that I'm interesting I'm sure I'm
associating people etc so the mentors
are positive and negatives you have the
people who are going to teach you what
are the mistakes do
and there are the people who are going
to inspire you by saying WOW I wouldn't
have never thought about this and I
think this is very very very powerful so
you'll learn from both and it's it's
that's why it's very important to listen
and observe and you know some people say
you know I have a boring boss you are
not learning anything it's a no wrong
wrong you have a boring boss it's an
opportunity to see why he's boring what
are the things you know what other
things I will learn that I will never
have to do in the future so I am NOT
boring for the people who are in my team
if you have a great boss from the
beginning you think you're going to
think it's very easy you know because
the guy is interesting and the objective
you're being hit etc you're not going to
learn as much as when you're going to be
facing adversity from the boss who has a
lot of imperfection obviously if you if
all your bosses are of this type is bad
also because you never know what you
know what is true north so having some
of both is very is very important I was
blessed by the fact that I had both and
frankly I learned as much from one than
from the from from the others
so while auto sales in the US have
remained flat or declined over the past
few years auto sales in many emerging
markets continue to grow at a
double-digit clip how is this dynamic
influence influenced Nissan and Renault
and how do you envision it impacting the
global auto industry well that's that's
a very important factor because we all
know that the car industry is moving
from north 2004 west to east in any kind
of summary the demand obviously the
United States Japan Europe are going to
continue to be important market but I
don't think growth is going to be an
important factor in these markets growth
is going to come from new markets
obviously we all know China in the other
Middle East South America but also from
the country of the future which are
going to be the next wave coming
Indonesia Iran Iraq Vietnam Mexico some
part of South America maybe some
countries in Africa this is the next
BRICS and you know we have a short
memory of you know
remember in 2000 the year 2000 10 years
ago not so much we used to sell 20,000
cars 10 to 20,000 cars a year in China
China was maybe the number in the car
industry it was market number 20 or 25
in 2009 was the largest market in the in
the world and I think it's going to be
sustainable and we sold 700,000 cars in
China in 10 years and this is becoming
one of the largest market of resound so
today what I want to know is in 10 years
what are the countries that's probably
not like China but are going to see
we're going to see this tremendous
growth so you look at the potential you
look at the resources you look at the
population you look at the mismanagement
usually the more the company is
mismatched the more the company or the
country is mismanaged the more potential
it has particularly has natural
resources so you look at the leadership
you look at the resources and then you
can start to list what are the countries
which has the most potential for the
next 10 years some of them will not
realize it because mismanagement may
continue or aggravate but some of them
are going to fix our problems and then
all of sudden they're going to they're
going to boom so for analyse on what
we're trying to do is take all these
countries which are the next generation
of BRICS and trying to establish a
presence in them some of them will not
bloom but the one room would be would be
really worth it what advice would you
give to newly minted MBAs and what
mistakes have you seen them make in the
early stages of their career what advice
I can give a new MBAs first I think I
think the first one is that don't plan
too much I does work for me didn't work
frankly don't plan too much your carrier
because we're going to be facing in life
is probably more powerful and much
bigger than you ever imagined
so if you're following your plan you may
miss a lot of opportunity coming on the
side but you don't even look at
I say oh I need to continue on my plan
okay even though on the side you're
going to be a huge opportunity coming
you don't look at them so don't plan too
much or be flexible on the planning
you're going to have a lot of ordering
particularly in the period we're getting
in 2010 2020
I think gonna be a lot of transformation
coming and they're going to be a lot of
opportunity so be flexible no matter
where you start you know some some of
you have already jobs some of you don't
no matter what you're going to start
with but if you really really put your
heart in it and your dedication in it at
the end of the day you're always going
to do great I've never seen personally
in my domain anybody working very
seriously wholeheartedly with a lot of
motivation openness on anything and at
the end of the day did not prevail never
seen this question of times question of
patience question of Drive that's that's
very that's very important the third the
third thing is it's also something very
important don't work for recognition
it's an illusion somebody was saying you
know if you want recognition buy
yourself a dog don't work for
recognition you're going to be
disappointed you're going to be
disappointed work for yourself obviously
work for no matter what are your
objective if you want to become wealthy
if you want to you know I mean work for
yourself but for it so I'm not saying
that we need to be a good centrist that
are looking no but but I think do not
put too much emphasis on the outside
what the outside is going to be bring
you because you're gonna be disappointed
you're going to be disappointed and I
want to tell you why why it's very
important to hold this line because
because when when you'll have to make
hard decisions and probably some of you
will have in the future you're going to
be long do not think that this is a team
it's not true at the end of the day the
guy is going to make the ultimate
decision is one and this guy is going to
do it alone
and he's going to do it based on his own
value and his own beliefs and his own
analysis transmitted by his team
wherever every but at the end of the day
he or she is doing the decision and when
you carry the decision you're going to
be more bartered no matter what so if
you're looking for an outside
recognition is going to melt you down
you can say oh my god that mean it's not
working everybody no no you need to have
your own strength you need to have your
own beliefs make your own analysis and
carry and carry the decision let me let
me give you an example obviously I'm
going to take the easiest one which is
the Nissan revival plan in 1999 when we
announced the plan in 1999 October 1999
where we were announcing a lot of
restructuring measures a lot of tough
decisions obviously the public opinion
was a little bit shocked that it was too
severe the financial market uploaded but
all finally somebody you know doing what
is right but the share collapsed 50
percent the Nissan share went down okay
let me say oh it's too risky may not
going to be successful etcetera so
you're standing alone you're doing
what's right with the public opinion
upset political parties upset financial
market letting you down you know and
you're only with your employee in the
dark you know and you say okay we're
going to make it and in one year we're
going to be profit and two years going
to be profitable so if you're asking for
recognition are you running bad shape
about you I'm going to tell you if
you're asking recognition even when you
succeed because you can say okay after
one year you made it after two years you
made it etc now the glory not at all not
that no not at all when we made the
profit of Nissan in 2000 in in 2000 in
the first year was the year 2000 the
press start say yeah you know what maybe
cook the book you know
2001 you repeat it yeah but it's easy to
cut cost it's different to grow the
company now you start to grow the
company yeah but where are the hits you
didn't do any car that now become very
famous now you do a car very famous and
say where's your technology man your
latent energy look at you can always
have something wrong always no matter
what no matter what so if you're looking
for the outside the things you're going
to be a little bit mislead you need to
have it in you and making sure that
you're looking at the right indicator
look at your own people with that we'd
like to open up to the audience for
questions please raise your hand and
wait for a mic before asking your
question hi Carlos thanks for being here
my name is Igor sorry for the jacket
actually actually I like your jacket you
know I am from Brazil and I would like
to so we we are hearing a lot about
Brazil lately and some people even
considered that it is almost like a
bubble that is just too much hype around
it I would love to hear your perspective
on the constraint more Nissan's and
Renault plan for the country no I think
I think Brazil it's a story which is
long do along you episode has a lot of
potential
obviously I'm I'm not talking if out of
emotion are worn in brazil i'm brazilian
etc but i think objectively brazil has a
very big future and frankly it's coming
late the question is not it's a bubble
it's not a bubble it's an anti bubble it
has been a very long time that we should
have seen what's happening today in
Brazil already in Brazil because Brazil
has everything every single thing every
aspect you looked at in Brazil has it
you know good demography young
population huge territory all the
resources energy I mean technology now
you know democracy I mean it's it's an
important element that mean this is a
stable country you know maybe still some
mismanagement cetera know Brazil has a
lot of potential frankly this is not a
bubble and I think Brazil is really well
below its potential and for
renault-nissan
this is one of the priority market for
us in terms of investment
and in terms of penetration Brazil is
long overdue what we're seeing today
should have happened ten years ago I'm
I'm glad it's happening you know and I
think there is more to come there is
more to come okay we have a question
over here um so we talked about the
girls difference in emerging markets
versus developed markets and I'm
wondering what's the implications do you
see in the in the market dynamics in the
auto industry overall and do you see the
companies the local companies in those
emerging markets as a threat and how
will just set your strategy going
forward and also just a like recently
we've seen a number of Chinese companies
acquire assets and foreign brands and
what's your view to do you think it will
be successful or not okay well I think
you know first thing I think in the next
10 years in the global market you'll
have at least one large Chinese car
maker at least one and you have at least
one Indian large karmak I have no doubt
about it and it's normal you're gonna
have a shrinking of the Western northern
car makers they're going to come
together and make alliances and at the
same time you're going to have something
generate we don't know who we don't know
how we don't know when but it's coming
no doubt about it that's number one
number two this will be facilitated or
the emergence of a big Chinese and the
emergence of a big Indian by how
short-sighted the other car
manufacturers are short-sighted we're
going to have not only one Indian but
two we're not going to have one Chinese
about five etc what does it mean but I'm
going to give you an example when Ratan
Tata came with the Nano you know a lot
of commences this is joke that is not a
car etc etc no no no that's a threat if
we neglect the Nano we're going to have
an Indian carmaker coming with the new
segment of the market three four
thousand dollar car that nobody's doing
and he's going to not only take by storm
the Indian market but start to develop
into a lot of emerging market and we're
going to repeat the story of the
Japanese industry versus European and US
industry and the Korean industry versus
Japanese which always start with I bring
a cheaper product and then I move up
that's the story of the Japanese
industry you know when the Japanese
industry started 40 years ago it started
with cheap
small low quality product and it moves
up and today it's a major part of the
car industry with every single problem
the Korean is the same they came with
the cheaper product than the Japanese
and are moving up well the engines and
the Chinese can do the same and if we
are short-sighted and say yeah you know
four thousand dollars car is not a
market for me I don't know how to do it
we're going to help generate more and
more Chinese and Indian so because of
this and you know because we've seen
this threat now what we're doing is we
are aligning with Indian and Chinese car
makers to make sure that we're not going
to be surprised by something like this
okay so this is going to slow down a
little bit the emergence of a pure
Chinese or a pure Indian but still I
think it's very unlikely that you don't
have at least one Chinese or at least
one Indian who become global eventually
by acquiring assets or making alliances
with other other major other major
companies but I don't think you're going
to have many of them I have a question
in the back
hi thank you for your time Brenden
Millstein second year MBA joint with
engineering school by going all-electric
with the leaf you're making a very
different bet than either Toyota or GM
is making and I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about that and
how you see green cars playing into I
guess a percent of your revenue in the
future yeah what you know we the green
car started we still taking the
leadership with the hybrid they took the
leadership on the highway and then Honda
came with a me-too product and Nissan
came with the me-too product and then GM
and everybody came with a me-too product
but they have already
taken the leadership technologically and
in term of brand by introducing the
hybrid that's fair and with all the
development of the hybrid plug-in hybrid
mild hybrid real hybrid etc the next
step is zero emission on the zero
emission we believe that there is a
market not on detriment of the hybrid
there is a market for hybrid but there
is a market for zero emission we said
okay we want to be the leader on zero
mission it's going to be good for our
brand we think there is a big market and
we have the technology for that so I
don't want you to think that we're doing
zero emission and electric car on
detriment of hybrids because we have
hybrids but on hybrids we recognize the
fact that the leadership is already
taken
ok we're followers we're going to bring
cars on the market we're going to
satisfy market demand but we will never
be recognized as leaders in hybrid and
in fact nobody is going to take this out
of Rotorua it's too too too late we want
to take the leadership on electric car
and we don't want anybody to take it
from us because we think objectively
there is a specific market for electric
cars why I think there is a specific
market for zero emission cars and not
hybrid and not anything else three
reasons mainly and in fact three
questions if you answer yes to the three
question then you say okay
zero mission car is going to be part of
the future the first question is do you
think very simple do you think even
though price of oil is unpredictable do
you think that there is more chance that
price of all in the future will go up or
down okay so if you say yes there is
more chance that it goes up well then
you are on the right path for electric
car if you think no no this is vague oil
there is plenty of it and it's going to
go down to twenty dollars then even you
should not even do hybrids you should
you should you should go back to
gasoline engine that's the first
question second question do you think
that the constraints on environment and
the regulation on the environment are
going to become stricter or looser if
you say it's going to become stricter
co2 emissions etc then you are also on
the right path for the zero the zero
emission car they're going to cost you
more and more to emit co2
and this is something which is going to
make a difference between these
technology and the others and the third
one is more strategic strategic concern
which is how much all the countries
which are developing in the world are
importing oil all of them China big
importer United States obviously Western
Europe obviously in Japan obviously but
even China and India which are the two
powerhouse coming they are big and net
importers of oil and there is no chance
no chance this is going to change for
the next 30 years so all these
superpowers economic superpowers how
long is going to accept that their
transportation sector depends only on
one commodity and they are not imported
of the Sikh community I remind you that
if one major oil producer for whatever
reason decide not to export oil and it's
happened in the past the transportation
system of most of these countries
paralyzed that's why it's considered a
strategic issue so the only way the only
way to disc disconnect this strategic
issue is to bring electricity why
because you can do electricity out of
oil of coal of natural gas of nuclear
power of hydroelectric of wind of solar
you can do literally out of everything
so if there is one community which
becomes very expensive or which become
unavailable you can switch to something
else
you can't in the case in the case of
water so there are a lot of reasons for
which you know we think that there is
absolutely no doubt that the
zero-emission car going to be part of
the future now the big question is is
going to be 10 percent 2000 2015 is
going to be 5 there is a lot of debate
going going on we are the most bullish
today by saying 10 percent of the market
2020 will be 0 mission
frankly I think the numbers will move up
and all the people who are today we
think it's going to be 1 percent 2
percent 3 percent they're going to make
kind of rolling forecasts which mean
every year they're going to update the
numbers you know so at the end of the
day you don't know what's their position
so we do you we're going to discover
we're going to discover a certain point
in time with 10 percent you are probably
the most conservative it will take a
very small
Isis for all these numbers to change it
will take an environmental disaster it
will take an energy crisis it will take
a war in a country which is large
producer with some diss control so
you're going to see these numbers going
to go up and and frankly the likelihood
that this happened in the next 10 year
is for me probability is near one that
you're going to have something happening
even if it doesn't happen it still makes
a lot of sense so we're going to see we
have different opinions or coming with
different technology it's not either/or
you know we have our hybrids but it is
where do you put most of your resources
in order to create leadership we have a
question over here
um hi I'm clay Calhoun I'm an MBA one
before I ask my question in the interest
of full disclosure I worked on the
automobile task force at the Treasury
Department this summer um and so i'd
like i'd really like your perspective on
broadly how you think the restructuring
of the US auto industry has changed or
hasn't changed the game for
renault-nissan and more specifically
returning to your comments on alliances
whether you think the Chrysler Fiat
Alliance has a chance of success or is
destined to kind of follow the previous
alliances into problems yeah we there
any journalists in the room or not it
can be on the website so we have to be
careful here I'm sorry we are on the
website so I'm gonna have to be very
polite and very no you know what I mean
I read I read the comment of Steve
Rattner and in fact it happened that I
was in a debate with Steve Rattner two
months ago in the Council of Foreign
Relations we were together and and Steve
were very straightforward he said he
said General Motors we were not going to
abandon no matter what too much
employment okay so it was clear from the
beginning
he said I've never seen people who are
so polite and so arrogant at the same
time he's coming you know this you've
been part of the he said it on record
it's unfortunate cetera and he said that
never seen a company which has been as
mismanaged and where there is so much so
few sense of emergency but you know
there is a new administration that could
not let GM go because employment they
calculated that the impact on employment
was huge that said we had to do
everything that we had to do to save
Jennifer's okay and frankly I think it's
very factual nobody nobody in the
industry and I can tell you because I've
seen many bankers and analysts and they
came to here this was before the
collapse two years before nobody would
have predicted even in the wildest
scenario and the wildest dream that
General Motors would become majority
owned by the US government
now nobody nobody has seen this scenario
nobody okay so which means that we have
to be very careful when we imagine the
future that it may always surprise us by
what kind of solution are put into place
so this is for Jenna Moore's for
Chrysler back to Steve Rattner he said
it was 4951 know it was funny 951 do let
it go do we give it to Fiat his comment
and at the end of the day he didn't say
exactly how it happened but probably
inspiration is you have you have to let
it you know put it on the 51 and let it
let it let's give it a try the bottom
line of this is the major element here
was employment the major element here
was protecting activities was not so
much about potential on the market or
competitiveness of the companies you
know and and frankly it's totally normal
because the French government moved to
serve guard its industry because of
employment Japanese government moved and
put a lot of cash and liquidity do
during the dark days of the crisis in
2008 and 2009
because of employment everybody look at
the industry with the prism of these
guys are big employers we just can't let
it let it go so this being said this
being said that mean which means that
the companies have been supported not in
function of their merit or that
potential but because of how much damage
this can create to the employment in the
industry there is no impossible mission
in our industry and I'm really well
positioned to tell you that because in
1990 nobody gave a clue about Nissan
being able to survive and we're doing
very well so I would I would not insult
the future by telling you there is no
chance there is always a chance depends
on how you manage how much focus you put
into it and you take the right decision
so I think I think it's still an open
it's still an open story we have a
question over here good afternoon good
afternoon mr. go use the get up once
again um given what you think given the
comments that you made about the
differences between Nissan and Renault
and the demands on a CEOs time and the
fact that synergies can be achieved and
have been achieved across companies in
multiple different ways it's not
immediately apparent to me that having a
single CEO is always the right choice
why has that been an effective choice in
this alliance yeah but I think it was
very right I'm not going to tell you
that single geo for two company is the
best choice and by the way when the line
started we there was not one single geo
I wish was there what he had off Renault
Hanna was on was the head of Nissan I
came as a CEO of Nissan two years after
I became the CEO of Nissan so which was
I was heading Renault I was heading
Nissan we were working together in 2005
which was err wanted to retire and
obviously he said you know you should be
my successor I'll say yeah but the
problem is I'm not going to abandon ISM
so how can you be successor and Renault
if you don't want to abandon Nissan
because I thought Nissan was still not
completely you know established even
though the results were good etc so we
came to the conclusion
that I would manage both everybody
thought it's crazy how can you manage I
mean two company on two different guns
etc etc but I think this was the most
reasonable solution not in absolute term
but at least for the temporary period
when the crisis started when the crisis
started I was realistic enough to say
okay you can't manage completely being
the CEO the CEO and the chairman of both
company at the same time we can't so
I've given up the CEO responsibility by
nominating one CEO at Nissan and one CEO
at Renault
she Ghassan is chief operating officer
based in Tokyo Pallotta
Patrick pelota is CEO based in Paris and
they follow the day-to-day operation and
they make sure that nobody's going to
say you know what was the boss we need
we need an answer here they're answering
all the question connected with me ok so
I'm keeping CEO role and chairman of
both company and delegating to the to
the CEOs is it going to be like this in
the future I don't think so we can come
back one day in a situation where you
have two different CEOs and you have a
kind of board of the lines which is
shared by one of them or a third a third
person so I don't want you to think that
this is the only solution to manage
Alliance a lot with I mean we have been
very very pragmatic into shaping it
thank you so much for joining us today I
had actually had a similar question to
the one that was asked by this young man
here and it's related to the goal the
role of the public sector and the
government in the industry in the future
you were talking about oil which is an
adjacent industry which thirty years ago
was more than 75 percent privatized but
today is more more than 90 percent owned
by the public by the public sector and
given what happened in the US last year
and also given that in China it's very
typical for the government to force
foreign players to have some sort of
local joint venture I was wondering how
you think that might affect the dynamics
of the industry going forward in the
coming years well you know I I
personally was not shocked by what
happened in 2008 and 2009 that mean
government's intervening particularly to
save employment I was not shocked I
think it's normal in situation of crisis
where
there is no more rules we're all system
shutdown somebody's going to have to
step and the market cannot step that
mean only government can step and why
they intervene with the car industry
that need to intervene in other
industries just because we are big large
employers that's it I mean government we
are driven by the fact that they didn't
want unemployment to go through the roof
that's a major motivation they don't
care about the cars a lot of people yeah
they don't care about us I mean I say
okay if if I don't have a national
producer I'll have somebody else I mean
in the United States that would have me
no problem to that one or two companies
collapse because we have so many already
capacity existing and competitors that
would be glad to take all these
positions
the question was employment and frankly
not only on the US and I think it's
totally normal I was affecting it and I
think it's sound that we don't give the
impression to society that there is a
problem there is a shot coming and
everybody retires or everybody hides
people have to stand up and face some of
the problems and I think they've done
the right things even though I'm not a
public interventionist I'm not a
politician but I think that what
governments have done during this crisis
where the right things to do because
when this crisis hit all the companies
were hit the good ones and the bad ones
the competitive ones and the not so
competitive ones everybody was it it's
like you know you take in a cleat and
you take a sick person you put them in
the room and you you stop oxygen well
both of them are going to die maybe the
sick guy is going to die a little bit
faster than the healthy guy but the
healthy guys going to die also if you
don't establish oxygen that's exactly
what happened with the cash situation in
2008 we were all under threat it was a
question of time government cannot stand
I say okay you know we're going to let
the market forces what market forces
there was no more cash the banks were
not working you know there is no market
forces at all you just have to establish
common sense so I think I think common
sense was established why some
governments it took some time to react
because frankly they did not understand
what was going on I personally spend a
lot of time with authorities in Japan
with authorities in France to explain
what was going on and frankly it helps a
lot for them understanding that this was
not a manipulation this was a renewed
federal government in the United States
and
and and the Fed reacted very well
because I started to listen to everybody
what's going on tell us when when the is
the cashier establish or not I think I
think most of the job done in 2008 and
2009 there were mistakes but overall the
reaction was sound but it's not visible
today probably five years down the road
when we analyze these facts we would
recognize the fact that many good things
many good things happen during this
period so back to your question I'm not
so favorable to public intervention into
markets but I think there are two cases
where it's necessary the first one is
when there is no more rules all of
sudden there is a collapse okay
government has to step in it was the
case 2008-2009 the second reason is when
you want to start something important
for example I'm going to give a
technological point batteries technology
today is something which we know is
essential for the next 20 or 30 years
the research on battery is mainly
concentrated between Japan Korea and
China the US government conscious of
this is saying this cannot be we need to
encourage development of research and
development in the United States and
they are putting money in it and putting
incentive and courage company that's
part of the job government says you need
to do recognized on a macro level that
there is something big missing in the
country and say okay we need to
establish the incentive and the
conditions to be able to bring back to
the conflict the Indian government's
doing that you know I was in India not
very long time ago I say there is no
battery company in India you know India
is proud saying we know we are the
country of knowledge you want to build
itself okay that's that's great where is
the battery technology it's missing from
India and they are thinking about
putting a kind of package to try to
encourage company to go into the sector
this for me makes a lot of sense these
are the two main condition on which you
require governments to intervene and
create the condition for the market to
to start and to perform mr. Khan thank
you so much for being with us today
thank you
that's why me this is my side
thank you very much